six five four three two one engines full
power and lift off at three six go
dragon Go falcon
[Applause]
's pitching down rage 1.7 million pounds
of
thrusty engines on the first stage whoa
oh my God
heard the call out indicating that the
first stage engines will begin to
Throttle Down in preparation for Max Q
which is the
is the aerodynamic pressure that the
vehicle will experience during flight
well it's supersonic
call up there indicating
traveling faster than the speed of sound
stage one
all right now that we're past Max Q
copy one Bravo
that one Bravo indicator are different
abort modes that are called as well as
indicate what series of Maneuvers Dragon
would indicate but so far we're hearing
good calls on the performance of the
Falcon 9
on his right uphill
copy two separation confirmed
there you can see on your screen
confirmation of stage separation as well
as ignition of that second stage engine
Escape system disarmed
for Dragon endeavors
attempting to land on our drone ship
just read the instructions
[Applause]
[Music]